we've made considerable progress in
battling kova 19.
when i became president
about 2 million americans were fully
vaccinated today
over 175 million americans have that
protection
before i took office we hadn't ordered
enough vaccine for american
just weeks in office we did
the week before i took office on january
20th of this year
over 25 000 americans died that week
covet 19.
last week that grim weekly toll
was down 70 percent
and then three months before i took
office our economy was faltering
creating just fifty thousand jobs a
month
we're now averaging seven hundred
thousand new jobs a month
in the past three months
this progress is real
but while america is much better shape
than it was seven months ago when i took
office
i need to tell you a second fact
we're in the tough stretch
and it could last for a while
highly contagious delta variant
that i began to warn america about back
in july spread late summer
like it did in other countries before us
while the vaccines provide strong
protection for the vaccinated we read
about and hear about and we see the
stories of hospitalized people people on
their death beds
among the unvaccinated over the past few
weeks
this is a pandemic of the unvaccinated
and it's caused by the fact that despite
america having unprecedented and
successful vaccination program
despite the fact that for almost five
months
free vaccines have been available in 80
000 different locations
we still have nearly 80 million
americans who have failed to get the
shot
and to make matters worse
there are elected officials
actively working to undermine the fight
against covet 19.
instead of encouraging people to get
vaccinated in a mask up
they're ordering mobile morgues
for the unvaccinated dying from coven in
their communities
this is totally unacceptable
third if you wonder how all this adds up
here's the math
the vast majority of americans are doing
the right thing
nearly three-quarters of the eligible
have gotten at least one shot
but one quarter has not gotten any
that's nearly 80 million americans not
vaccinated
and a country as large as ours that's 25
percent
minority that 25 percent can cause a lot
of damage and they are
the unvaccinated overcrowd our hospitals
are overrunning emergency rooms and
intensive care units
leaving no room for someone with a heart
attack or pancreatis or cancer
and fourth
i want to emphasize
that the vaccines provide very strong
protection
from severe illness from covet 19.
i know there's a lot of confusion and
misinformation
but the world's leading scientists
confirm
that if you are fully vaccinated your
risk of severe illness from covet 19 is
very low
in fact
based on available data from the summer
only one out of every 160 000 fully
vaccinated americans
was hospitalized for covid per day
these are the facts
so here's where we stand
the path ahead
even with the delta variant
is not nearly as bad as last winter
but what makes it incredibly more
frustrating
is we have the tools to combat coven 19
and a distinct minority of americans
supported by a stink minority of elected
officials are keeping us from turning
the corner
these pandemic politics as i refer to
are
making people sick
causing unvaccinated people to die
we cannot allow these actions
to stand in the way of protecting the
large majority of americans who have
done their part
i want to get back to life as normal
as your president
i'm announcing tonight
a new plan to require more americans to
be vaccinated to combat those blocking
public health
my plan also increases testing
protects our economy
and will make our kids safer in schools
it consists of six broad areas of action
and many specific measures in each
that each of those actions you can read
more about in whitehouse.gov
whitehouse.gov
the measures
these are going to take time
to have full impact
but if we implement them
i believe and the scientists indicate
that the months ahead we can reduce the
number of unvaccinated americans
decrease hospitalizations and deaths
and allow our children to go to school
safely
and keep our economy strong by keeping
businesses open
first
we must increase vaccinations among the
unvaccinated with new vaccination
requirements
the nearly 80 million eligible americans
who have not gotten vaccinated
many said they were waiting for approval
from the food and drug administration
the fda
well last month the fda granted that
approval
so the time for waiting is over
this summer we made progress through the
combination of vaccine requirements and
incentives as well as the fda approval
four million more people
got their first shot in august than they
did in july
but we need to do more
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
my job as president is to protect all
americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week
some of the biggest companies are
already requiring this
united airlines
disney
tyson's food
and even fox news
the bottom line
we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers
we're going to reduce the spread of
covet 19 by increasing the share of the
workforce that is vaccinated
in businesses all across america
my plan will extend the vaccination
requirements
that i previously issued in the health
care field
already i've announced we'll be
requiring vaccinations that all nursing
home workers
who treat patients on medicare and
medicaid because i have that federal
authority
tonight i'm using that same authority
to expand that to cover those who work
in hospitals
home health care facilities or other
medical facilities
a total of 17 million health care
workers
if you're seeking care
at a health facility you should be able
to know
that the people treating you are
vaccinated simple straightforward period
next
i will sign an executive order
that will now require all executive
branch federal employees to be
vaccinated all
and i've signed another executive order
that will require federal contractors
to do the same
if you want to work with the federal
government and do business with us get
vaccinated
if you want to do business with the
federal government vaccinate your
workforce
and tonight
i'm removing one of the last remaining
obstacles that make it difficult for you
to get vaccinated
the department of labor will require
employers with 100 or more workers
to give those workers paid time off to
get vaccinated
no one should lose pay
in order to get vaccinated or take a
loved one to get vaccinated
today in total
the vaccine requirements in my plan will
affect about 100 million americans
two-thirds of all workers
and for other sectors
i issue this appeal
to those of you running large
entertainment venues
from sports arenas to concert venues to
movie theaters please require folks to
get vaccinated
or show a negative test as a condition
of entry
and to the nation's family physicians
pediatricians
gps general practitioners
you're the most trusted medical voice to
your patients
you may be the one person who can get
someone to change their mind about being
vaccinated
tonight
i'm asking each of you to reach out to
your unvaccinated patients over the next
two weeks
and make a personal appeal to that
to get the shot
america needs your personal involvement
in this critical effort
my message to unvaccinated americans is
this
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see
we've made vaccinations free
safe and convenient
the vaccine is fda approval
over 200 million americans have gotten
at least one shot
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
so please do the right thing
but just don't take it from me me
listen to the voices of unvaccinated
americans
who are lying in hospital beds
taking their final breath saying if only
i'd gotten vaccinated
if only it's a tragedy
please don't let it become yours
the second piece of my plan
is continuing to protect the vaccinated
for the vast majority of you who've
gotten vaccinated i understand your
anger
at those who haven't gotten vaccinated
i understand the anxiety about getting a
breakthrough case
but as the science makes clear
if you're fully vaccinated
you're highly protected from severe
illness
even if you get covet 19.
in fact recent data indicates
there is only one confirmed positive
case per 5 000 fully vaccinated
americans per day
you're as safe as possible
and we're doing everything we can to
keep it that way keep it that way keep
you safe
that's where boosters come in
the shots that give you even more
protection than after your second shot
now
i know there's been some confusion about
boosters so let me be clear
last month
our top government doctors announced
an initial plan
for booster shots for vaccinated
americans
they believe that the booster is likely
to provide the highest level of
protection yet
of course the decision
of which booster shots to give when to
start them and who will give them
will be left completely to the
scientists at the fda and the centers
for disease control
but while we wait
we've done our part
we bought enough boosters enough booster
shots
and the distribution system is ready to
administer them
as soon as they are authorized those
eligible will be able to get a booster
right away
in tens of thousands of sites across the
sites across the country
for most americans
at your nearby drugstore and for free
the third piece of my plan
is keeping and maybe the most important
is keeping our children safe and our
schools open
for any parent
it doesn't matter how low the risk
of any illness or accident is when it
comes to your child or grandchild
trust me i know
so
let me speak to you directly
let me speak to you directly to help
ease some of your worries
it comes down to two separate categories
children ages 12 and older who are
eligible for a vaccine now
and children ages 11 and under who are
not yet eligible
the safest thing for your child 12 and
older
is to get them vaccinated
they get vaccinated for a lot of things
that's it get them vaccinated
as of adults almost all the serious cova
19 cases were seen among adolescents
are an unvaccinated 12 to 17 year olds
an age group that lags behind in
vaccination rates
so parents
please get your teenager vaccinated
what about children under the age of 12
who can't get vaccinated yet
well
the best way for a parent to protect
their child under the age of 12 starts
at home
every parent
every teen sibling
every caregiver around them
should be vaccinated
children have four times higher chance
of getting hospitalized if they live in
a state
with low vaccination rates rather than
states with high vaccination rates
now if you're a parent of a young child
you're wondering when will it be when
will it be the vaccine available for
them
i strongly support independent
scientific review
for vaccine uses for children under 12.
we can't take shortcuts for that
scientific work
but i've made it clear i will do
everything within my power
to support the fda with any resource it
needs to continue to do this as safely
and as quickly as possible
and our nation's top doctors are
committed to keeping the public at large
updated on the process so parents can
plan
now to the schools
we know that if schools follow the
science
and implement the safety measures like
testing
masking
adequate ventilation systems which we
provided the money for
social distancing and vaccinations
then children can be safe from covet 19
in schools
today
about 90 of school staff and teachers
are vaccinated
we should get that to 100
my administration has already acquired
teachers
at the schools run by the defense
department because i have the authority
as president of the federal system the
defense department and the interior
department
to get vaccinated
that's the authority i possess
tonight i'm announcing
that will require all of nearly
300 000 educators in the federal hep
paid program head start programs
must be vaccinated as well to protect
your youngest
our youngest most precious americans
and give parents to comfort
and tonight
i'm calling on all governors to require
vaccinations for all teachers and
staff some already have done so
we need more to step up
vaccination requirements in schools are
nothing new
they work
they're overwhelmingly supported by
educators and their unions
and all school officials trying to do
the right thing by our children
i'll always be on your side
let me be blunt
my plan also takes on elected officials
in states that are undermining you
in these life-saving actions
right now
local school officials are trying to
keep children safe in a pandemic while
their governor
picks a fight with them
and even threatens their salaries or
their jobs
talk about bullying in schools
if they'll not help if these governors
won't help us beat the pandemic
i'll use my power as president to get
them out of the way
the department of education
has already begun to take legal action
against states undermining protection
that local school officials have ordered
any teacher or school official
whose pays with hell for doing the right
thing
we will have that pay restored by the
federal government 100
i promise you i will have your back
fourth piece of my plan
is increasing testing and masking
from the start america has failed to do
enough
cova 19 testing
in order to better detect and control
the double variant
i'm taking steps tonight to make testing
more available more affordable and more
convenient
i'll use the defense production act to
increase production of rapid tests
including those that you can use at home
while that production is ramping up
my administration has worked with top
retailers like walmart amazon and
krogers
and tonight we're announcing that no
later than next week each of these
outlets will start to sell at home rapid
test kits
at cost
for the next three months
this immediate
price reduction
for at home test kits for up to 35
percent reduction
we'll also expand expand free testing
at 10 000 pharmacies around the country
and we'll commit we're committing two
billion dollars
to purchase nearly 300 million rapid
tests for distribution to community
health centers
food banks
schools
so that every american no matter their
income
can access free and convenient tests
this is important to everyone
particularly for a parent or a child
with a child not old enough to be
vaccinated
you'll be able to test them at home
and test those around them
in addition
to testing we know masking helps stop
the spread of covet 19.
that's why when i came into office i
required masks for all federal buildings
on on federal lands on airlines and
other modes of transportation
today
tonight
i'm announcing
that the transportation safety
administration the tsa
will double the fines on travelers that
refuse to mask
if you break the rules
be prepared to pay
and by the way
show some respect
the anger you see on television toward
flight attendants and others doing their
job is wrong it's ugly
the fifth piece of my plan
is protecting our economic recovery
because of our vaccination program
and the american rescue plan which we
passed thoroughly in my administration
we've had record job creation for a new
administration
economic growth unmatched in 40 years
we cannot let unvaccinated
do
this progress undo it
turn it back
so tonight i'm announcing additional
steps to strengthen our economic
recovery we'll be expanding covet 19
economic
injury disaster loan programs
that's a program that's going to allow
small businesses to borrow up to 2
million
from the current 500 000
to keep going if covet 19 impacts on
their sales
these low-interest long-term loans
require no repayment for two years
and be can use to hire and retain
workers
purchase inventory or even pay down
higher cost debt racked up since the
pandemic began
i'll also be taking additional steps to
help small businesses stay afloat during
the pandemic
sixth we're going to continue to improve
the care
of those who do get covet 19.
in early july
i announced the deployment of surge
response teams
these are teams comprised of experts
from the department of health and human
services
the cdc
the defense department
and the federal emergency management
agency fema to areas in the country
that need help to stem the spread of
covet 19.
since then
the federal government has deployed
nearly 1 000 staff
including doctors
nurses
paramedics
into 18 states
today
i'm announcing that the defense
department will double the number of
military health teams
that they'll deploy to help their fellow
americans and hospitals around the
country additionally we're increasing
the availability of new medicines
recommended by real doctors not
conspiracy conspiracy theorists
the monoclonal on antibody treatments
have been shown to reduce the risk of
hospitalization up to 70 percent for
unvaccinated people at risk of
developing severe
severe disease
we've already distributed 1.4 million
courses of these treatments to save
lives
and reduce the strain on hospitals
tonight
i'm announcing we will increase the
average pace of shipment across the
country of free monoclonal antibody
treatments by another 50
before i close
let me say this
communities of color are
disproportionately impacted by this
virus
and as we continue to battle kova 19
we will ensure that equity continues to
be at the center of our response
will ensure that everyone is reached
my first responsibility as president is
to protect the american people and make
sure we have enough vaccine for every
american including enough boosters
for every american who's approved to get
one
we also know this virus transcends
borders
that's why even as we execute this plan
at home
we need to continue fighting the virus
overseas
continue to be the arsenal of vaccines
we're proud to have donated nearly 140
million vaccines over 90 countries more
than all other countries combined
including europe china and russia
combined
that's american leadership on a global
stage
and that's just the beginning
we've also now started to ship another
500 million
coveted vaccines pfizer vaccines
purchased to donate to 100 lower-income
countries in need of vaccines
and i'll be announcing additional steps
to help the rest of the world later this
month
as i recently released
the key parts of my pandemic
preparedness plan
so that america isn't caught flat-footed
with a new pandemic comes look at
as it will
next month i'm also going to release a
plan in greater detail
so let me close with this
we have so we've made so much progress
during the past seven months of this
pandemic
the recent increases in vaccinations in
august
already are having an impact in some
states where case counts are dropping in
recent days
even so
we remain at a critical moment a
critical time
we have the tools
now we just have to finish the job with
truth
with science with confidence
and together
as one nation
look we're the united states america
there's nothing not a single thing we're
unable to do if we do it together
so let's stay together
god bless you all
and all those who continue to serve on
the front lines of this pandemic
and may god protect our
troops get vaccinated
[Music]
you heard that last message from the
president get vaccinated a bit of a
stern tone from the president this
evening laying out his six step plan to
combat the rise in the coronavirus cases
in it new vaccination requirements that
will impact 100 million americans or
roughly two-thirds of the workforce for
the vaccinated booster shots once they
are available the president urged
parents to get their kids 12 and up the
shots and called on governors to require
all teachers and school staff to be
vaccinated his plan called for increased
testing and masking and he said if you
refuse to wear a mask while flying he is
calling on the tsa to double the federal
fines on those who fight back against
travel agents the president said he is
frustrated not only with those who
refuse to get the vaccine but also those
state and local leaders who have rolled
back or blocked mass mandates he said
while this winter won't be as bad as
last winter he called it a tough stretch
that could last a while stay tuned for
this to the station for all the latest
from washington i'm lauren blanchard
this has been the fox news special
report